ende der enns priorisierung nach der
konferenz von bund und ländern kündigt
kanzlerin merkel an dass sich spätestens
im juni alle anmelden können trauriger
jahrestag in der ukraine 35 jahre nach
dem reaktorunfall von tschernobyl leidet
die region noch immer unter der
radioaktiven belastung lounge gefühl
statt mega-show hollywood verleiht die
oscars im kleineren kreis und zeichnet
mehr nichtweiße stars mit der begehrten
statuen aus
guten abend willkommen bei den 19 uhr
nachrichten norbert lehmann ist wieder
mit dabei diese woche für den sport
hunderte von mir alle paar wochen ist
gipfeltag carola gipfeltag heute ging es
bei dem spitzengespräch von
bundeskanzlerin und ländern ums impfen
und diesmal ging alles recht schnell
zwei themen standen im vordergrund ob
man das impfen inzwischen nicht für alle
altersgruppen freigeben sollte und die
frage ob sich zwei mal geimpfte wieder
freier bewegen dürfen
tatsächlich dürfen für die doppelt
geimpften bald manche beschränkungen
wegfallen etwa beim zugang zu geschäften
oder beim besuch von angehörigen in
pflegeheimen oder die quarantäne nach
rückreisen aus risikoländern freiheit
nur für geimpfte soll es aber nicht
geben und sie müssen auch weiter masken
tragen mit der strengen im freien folge
soll wohl spätestens im juni schluss
sein
andrea maurer es ist woche 18 nach dem
start in deutschland das impfen gewinnt
an dynamik und damit auch die frage wann
und ob grundrechts einschränkungen für
geimpfte aufgehoben werden zwei stunden
haben kanzlerin und länderchefs beraten
pressekonferenz in berlin
heute ging es eigentlich um freiheit und
freiheiten und so schön war das heute
eine hoffnungs mgk im vergleich zu den
vielen vielen ps die wie ratten mussten
die größten schäden zu verhindern einer
rechtsverordnung mit zustimmung des
bundestags soll nun für millionen
geimpfte und genesene auf den weg
gebracht werden wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse machten dies zwingend
es gibt eine klare aussage des robert
koch instituts zur gefahrenlage sowohl
für die betroffenen selbst wie auch
welche gefährdung geht noch von ihnen
aus wenn sie geimpft sind für andere und
damit müssen wir uns auseinandersetzen
wenn es so eine einschätzung gibt dass
diese menschen doch sich sehr sicher
bewegen können im öffentlichen raum auch
um die frage wann die impf priorisierung
aufgehoben wird ging es bei dem
spitzentreffen schon im zug nach berlin
hatte der bayerische ministerpräsident
patrick die rasche aufhebung gefordert
dem erteilt die kanzlerin ein
dämpfer im großen und ganzen gehen wir
davon aus dass in der prioritäten gruppe
3 die impfungen die erstimpfung im laufe
des monats mai stattfinden können so
dass wir dann spätestens je nachdem wie
viele impfdosen wir bekommen
ab juni aber ich sage nochmal spätestens
die priorisierungen aufgeben können ab
juni sollen auch die betriebsärzte mit
einsteigen das heißt nicht dass im juni
alle geimpft sein so die kanzlerin
aber jeder und jede habe dann die
möglichkeit einen termin zu vereinbaren
ja fragen an theo koll in unserem
hauptstadtstudio tee und soll die in
freien folge erst im juni freigegeben
werden
einige länderchefs folgen das ja früher
wer hat sich da durchgesetzt nun
gesundheitsminister sparen hatte in
einem eingangsreferat noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen dass viele millionen
menschen aus der sogenannten
priorisierung gruppe 3 schon seit
monaten auf eine impfung warten und die
müssten jetzt zuerst dran kommen denn
das sind vor allem menschen die in ihrem
beruf vielen kontakten ausgesetzt sind
also beispielsweise die kassierer im
supermarkt der busfahrer das
lehrpersonal die impfung dieser gruppe 3
sollte aber im mai zu schaffen sein und
deshalb wäre dann spätestens im juni die
priorisierung aufgegeben aber eben auch
erst danach könnte sich jeder um einen
impftermin bewerben was aber auch
ausdrücklich nicht bedeutet sofort einen
termin zu bekommen dennoch bei insgesamt
80 millionen impfdosen im zweiten
quartal sollten dann sehr viele sehr
schnell geimpft werden auch weil die
betriebsärzte dann mit impfen dürfen die
stimmung dieses gipfels sei sehr gut
gewesen sagen die beteiligten woran
lag's es war sogar so dass einige
beteiligte die veranstaltung als ein
gipfel der hoffnung bezeichnet haben
allgemein spürbar war natürlich die
erleichterung dass es bei den impfungen
jetzt mit großem tempo oder größerem
tempo voran geht das wird von allen als
es eigentlich wichtige und hilfreiche
angesehen und heute stand noch keine
entscheidung an auch das ist bei solchen
runden ja hilfreich und die
rechtsverordnung mit der geimpfte und
genesene wieder bestimmte rechte
zurückbekommen
die muss erst noch vom bund geschrieben
werden also auch da blieb es ohne
aktuellen entscheidungsdruck vielen dank
wie weiter in der korona pandemie zum
impfgipfel von bund und ländern gibt es
ein zdf spezial direkt im anschluss an
diese heute -sendung erleichterungen für
geimpfte im moment würden davon fast
sechs millionen menschen in deutschland
profitieren sie sind bereits zweimal
geimpft knapp 13,5 millionen haben
bereits ihre erste spritze bekommen
insgesamt liegt die impfquote in
deutschland bei 23 prozent und die zahl
wird weiter ansteigen weil die
impfstoffmengen mehr werden
volker dutschek der motor in den
impfzentren kommt langsam auf touren
in der april werden die hersteller von
bio tech moderner und astrazeneca knapp
neun millionen dosen geliefert haben im
juni sind es fast 12 4 millionen in den
arztpraxen zündet der impf turbo ab
jetzt nachdrücklich in dieser woche
können rund zwei millionen dosen
angeboten werden nächste woche 3
millionen im juni könnten mehr als 17
millionen impfungen dazu kommen bis ende
juni haben die hersteller laut
gesundheitsministerium 80 millionen
impfdosen zugesagt etwa 50 millionen
sind von bayern tech pfizer dessen
pünktliche lieferung gelten als garant
für eine schnelle immunisierung in
deutschland das neue werk im hessischen
marburg ist die weltgrößte drehscheibe
für impfstoffe 250 millionen dosen
werden bis mitte des jahres ausgeliefert
weitere 500 millionen werden dort bis
zum jahresende produziert viele blicken
also hoffnungsvoll in richtung
frühsommer ab dann könnte jeder ein
impfangebot bekommen bisher ist die
impfquote zwischen den bundesländern
unterschiedlich beispiel niedersachsen
das liegt im unteren drittel will jetzt
aber tempo machen und geht dafür auch
ungewöhnliche wege
elisabeth schmidt es kann so schnell
gehen ranfahren ärmel hoch ein piekser
und schon gehts weiter
im streifen in hildesheim niedersachsen
will schneller die wartelisten abbauen
und setzt dabei auch auf sonderaktionen
wie diese menschen über 70 jahre und
chronisch kranke der priorisierung
gruppe 2 bekommen den impfstoff von
astrazeneca gespritzt
mal zehn minuten also wir sind wirklich
sofort angekommen sofort durchgewunken
sofort geimpft alles ganz prima wenn man
also leute sieht in der intensivstation
liegen und wie wieder liegen das möchte
ich also nicht und deshalb lasse ich
mich impfen 1000 menschen haben hier
allein an diesem wochenende ihre erste
impfung bekommen nach der spritze müssen
die patienten noch eine viertelstunde
auf dem parkplatz warten um mögliche
nebenwirkungen auszuschließen
sie sehen ja es wird ja sehr gut
angenommen es gibt ja viele menschen die
eben doch sagen ja also für uns kommt
astrazeneca als impfstoff eben doch in
frage
die hausärzte drücken beim impfen
ebenfalls aufs tempo diese woche werden
an die praxen deutschlandweit eine halbe
million dosen mehr geliefert als
erwartet je mehr desto besser sagt auch
hausarzt dr mühlenfeld das können wir
schaffen das wollen wir auch schaffen
weil wir natürlich möglichst schnell und
möglichst intensiv die patienten
versorgen wollen und dazu werden wir nun
falls dann auch in hoher stunden machen
auch in diesem impfzentrum auf dem
messegelände in hannover würden sie
gerne mehr arbeiten
allein es fehlt derzeit noch an
impfstoff der soll aber kommen im mai
davon gehen die verantwortlichen aus
könnten hier bis zu 55.000 menschen pro
woche geimpft werden
fast doppelt so viele wie bislang und
der blick auf die zahlen zeigt sie sind
weiterhin hoch
das robert koch institut meldet 11 1907
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 470 mehr als vergangenen montag 60
todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sieben tage incidents steigt auf
169,3 wie immer nach dem wochenende sind
die gemeldeten zahlen weniger
aussagekräftig schon lange gibt es
streit zwischen der eu und astrazeneca
jetzt hat die eu kommission klage
eingereicht gegen das pharmaunternehmen
der grund die impfstofflieferungen
astrazeneca hat bislang deutlich weniger
corona impfstoff geliefert als von der
eu erwartet der britisch schwedische
konzern wehrt sich man habe die
vertraglichen verpflichtungen erfüllt
heißt es ein erster gerichtstermin soll
übermorgen stattfinden
im corona jahr 2020 ist in deutschland
die zahl der todesfälle gestiegen
laut statistischem bundesamt ist dabei
unklar wie groß der einfluss der
pandemie auf die sterberate ist nach den
jetzt veröffentlichten zahlen sind im
vergangenen jahr rund 986 1000 menschen
gestorben
das waren 46.000 mehr als 2009 10
das entspricht einer zunahme um 5
prozent heute vor genau 35 jahren
ereignet sich eine katastrophe die die
welt verändert in der heutigen ukraine
in tschernobyl wird der reaktorblock 4
im atomkraftwerk einem sicherheitscheck
unterzogen
es passiert das unvorstellbare es kommt
zur kernschmelze und zu zwei schweren
explosionen
die wucht zerreißt das dach des
reaktorblocks eine meterdicke
betonkonstruktion soll danach die
gefährliche strahlen quelle versiegeln
doch sie wird schnell brüchig 2017 ist
schließlich ein gewaltiger sarkophag
fertiggestellt er wird über die
reaktorruine geschoben tschernobyl 2021
christian senn berichtet gedenken in der
nacht an die verstorbenen arbeiter und
feuerwehrleute auch 35 jahre nach der
atomkatastrophe sitzt der schmerz noch
immer tief mindestens 30 menschen
starben direkt nach dem unglück die zahl
der strahlen toten ist noch immer
umstritten mehrere tausend menschen
starben in den jahren danach an den
folgen
meine freunde mein mann alle die männer
waren sind nicht mehr da es sind diese
bilder die sich ins kollektive
gedächtnis eingebrannt haben die
katastrophe von tschernobyl am 26
april 1986 heute überspannt ein
gigantischer 109 meter hoher sarkophag
aus stahl die atomruine rund 2800
menschen arbeiten doch in dem kraftwerk
sie ist religiös hier ist die
strahlenbelastung akzeptabel um sich
hier für einige zeit aufzuhalten
eine schicht lang kann man hier sicher
arbeiten als im letzten jahr die
radioaktiv verseuchten wälder rund um
die atomruine brannten wuchs die sorge
vor einer neuen gefahr dieser rauch ist
sehr radioaktiv dadurch den brand
radionuklide in großer menge in die luft
geraten
die strahlung innerhalb der 30 kilometer
sperrzone ist unterschiedlich hoch in
bekannten hotspots kann sie tausendfach
über dem normalwert liegen
trotzdem kommen touristen aus aller welt
auch in die geisterstadt pripjat
tschernobyl auch instagram hotspot da
der mensch hier nur noch wenig eingreift
vermehren sich trotz radioaktivität
luchse wölfe oder elche neues leben in
einer eigentlich lebensfeindlichen gegen
die russischen behörden gehen weiter
gegen kremlkritiker navalny vor dessen
organisationen dürfen nicht mehr
arbeiten wie ein moskauer gericht
entschieden hat
betroffen ist davon beispielsweise ist
anti korruptions stiftung
die staatsanwaltschaft will die
organisation in einem nächsten schritt
als extremistisch verbieten lassen
die bundesregierung verurteilt das
vorgehen der russischen justiz in der
türkei wo heute ein prozess gegen mehr
als 100 menschen beginnt darunter viele
führende mitglieder der prokurdischen
partei hdp und darum geht es
die angeklagten sollen 2014 an teils
gewalttätigen protesten beteiligt
gewesen sein
die demonstrierenden hatten das
türkische militär aufgefordert in der
nordsyrischen stadt kubaner einzugreifen
um die dort lebenden kurden
den angriffen der us terror miliz zu
verteidigen
glück weil dort berichtet vor dem
hochsicherheitsgefängnis in ankara ein
martialisches polizeiaufgebot drinnen
teils tumultartige szenen weil das
gericht nicht allen strafverteidigern
einlass gewähren wollte angeklagt sind
108 politikerinnen und politiker der
prokurdischen ra dp darunter auch der
frühere parteivorsitzende der tasche der
seit 2016 im gefängnis sitzt obwohl der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte bereits zweimal seine
freilassung angeordnet hat
staatspräsident erdogan interessiert das
aber nicht die urteile aus europa können
unsere gerichtsurteile nicht ersetzen
worum geht es im verfahren 2014
belagerten es terroristen die kurdische
grenzstadt kubaner ankara weigerte sich
den syrischen kurden zu helfen
die hd berief daraufhin zu protesten
gegen die regierung erdogan auf die
teils sehr blutige gewalt umschlugen mit
mehr als 30 toten
die staatsanwaltschaft fordert deshalb
mehrfacher lebenslange haftstrafen für
die angeklagten
für den hdp vorsitzenden sancha ein
beleg dafür
die regierung versucht demokratische
opposition auszuschalten
es ist keine schlechte justiz es ist
keine mangelhaft
die regierung hat nach den worten von
präsidentensprecher alten vollstes
vertrauen in die justiz es sei zeit für
die mörder so alten wörtlich für ihre
taten zu zahlen auch in corona zeiten
rüstet die weltweite auf das hat das
schwedische friedensforschungsinstitut
sipri errechnet demnach haben alle
länder zusammen im vergangenen jahr fast
2000 milliarden us-dollar in ihr militär
investiert mit großem abstand vorne vor
china und indien liegen die usa
deutschland kommt auf platz sieben und
zwar mit einem besonders starken zuwachs
um 5,2 prozent auf knapp 53 milliarden
us-dollar lounge gefühl statt großem
publikum die korona pandemie war bei der
oscar gala noch immer zu spüren
doch viele stars kam trotzdem auf den
roten teppich nach los angeles
zwei trends waren klar zu spüren der
jury fiel mehr nischen filme als bisher
auf wie nomad land mit frances mcdormand
und diesmal erhielten mehr nichtweiße
filmschaffende die begehrten statuen aus
den usa berichtet benjamin daniel es war
diesmal nicht der abend der ganz großen
stars zum glück wurde das
namensgedächtnis per tablet gleich am
anfang aufgefrischt
die verleihung als film inszeniert der
saal wie eine kulisse in einem bahnhof
in los angeles nein mit mangelnder
kreativität hatte hollywood noch nie ein
problem
[Applaus]
soziales gewissen und vielfalt sollen
das neue gesicht der oscars sein noch
nie waren so viele people of colour für
wichtige preise nominiert gewinnen das
abendland bester film beste regie und
für ihre rolle der firmen die im camper
durch die usa fährt erhält frances
mcdormand den oscar für die beste
weibliche hauptrolle
[Musik]
der preis für die beste männliche
hauptrolle geht an anthony hopkins in
der farbe auch abseits des filmischen
gab es bemerkenswerte momente wie der
als sich comedian treffer free zum thema
polizeigewalt äußerte im schnitt tötet
die polizei in den usa an die 1000
menschen jedes jahr mehrheitlich
schwarze menschen bitte lassen sie sich
unser leid nicht egal sein wenn man die
umstände bedenkt war es wohl eine
gelungene aufführung und trotzdem bleibt
der eindruck glamour und bahnhofshalle
gehen eben schwer zu sammeln nun zur
fußball-bundesliga da gibt es spannende
personal in aber ganz schön was los
fangen wir mit münchen und leipzig an
rb sportchef markus krösche hat seinen
vertrag vorzeitig aufgelöst und trainer
julian nagelsmann wird von den bayern
heftig umworben als nachfolger von hansi
flick der als neuer bundestrainer im
gespräch ist steht diese wachablösung
bald bevor nagelsmann für flick die
bayern haben leipzig ein offizielles
angebot gemacht und nagelsmann soll um
vertragsauflösung gebeten haben eine
steile karriere vor sechs jahren noch
unbekannter jugendcoach in hoffenheim
mitte 20 ist er damals und noch keine
dreißig als jüngster hauptamtlicher
bundesliga trainer ärgert nagelsmann die
großen bayern bereits mehrmals
ärmlich zupackend konzept in einer neuen
generation vornehmer gekleidet in
europas königsklasse
leipzig die nächste station nagelsmann
formt einem deutschen spitzenclub und
champions league halbfinalisten sein
größter erfolg bisher den bayern muss er
eine mittlere zweistellige
millionensumme wert sein
ob er ihnen wohl so viel schwung
verleihen kann wie vor jahren seinen
hoffenheimer kollegen und auch in
augsburg dreht sich das trainerkarussell
der abstiegsbedrohte fc r hat seinen
coach heiko herrlich heute entlassen
morgen wird sein nachfolger vorgestellt
ex augsburg trainer markus weinzierl ein
jahr ko-runde blinkte pause jetzt wird
in münchen wieder ein atp turnier auf
sand gespielt bei den bmw open
und da hat der deutsche tennisprofi
maximilian mattera
seine erste partie verloren der 25 jahre
alte nürnberger unterlag dem litauer
ricardas berankis mit 6 7 und 3 6
deutschlands bester tennisprofi
alexander zverev der wird am mittwoch
ins turnier eingreifen
das war's vom sport sagte kühl aber
sonnig geht diese woche zunächst weiter
was sich ab donnerstag ändert das sagt
uns gleich katja honnef das war es von
uns danke für ihr interesse
mir zum heutigen gipfeltag dann im heute
journal mit marietta slomka um drei
viertel 10
und wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen
wieder dabei sind punkt 19 uhr einen
schönen sonnigen abend noch hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit dem spezial tschüss
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute gab es viel
sonnenschein und nur über denen und
osten zogen einige kleine schauer hinweg
am morgen wanders sogar noch
schneeschauer
sonst aber gab es viel sonnenschein ist
blieb allerdings vor allen dingen an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee sehr kühl da
gab es heute nachmittag eine
höchsttemperaturen von acht oder neun
grad am oberrhein ging es dagegen bis 19
grad drauf jetzt in der nacht ist es
meist klar
und deswegen wird es wieder sehr kalt
ist droht nicht nur bodenfrost sondern
auch luftfrost also frost in zwei meter
höhe zwischen nordfriesland und der
donau aber auch richtung lüneburger
heide und lausitz sinken die
temperaturen auf minus ein bis minus
fünf grad und morgen bleibt es dann im
norden und im osten auch recht kühl mit
höchstwerten zwischen 10 grad auf rügen
und maximal 14 grad zum beispiel am
alpenrand nur am rhein und westlich
davon gibt es immerhin 15 bis 19 grad
und auch morgen gibt's jede menge
sonnenschein wolkenfelder höchstens mal
im nordosten oder alpen hat die uv
gefahr ist allerdings groß schon bereits
nach 20 minuten bekommen sie mit heller
mitteleuropäische haut einen sonnenbrand
hier bei einem uv-index von 6 am
mittwoch ändert sich an diesem wetter
noch wenig am donnerstag dreht der wind
dann kommen die heiß ersehnten
regenfälle
schönen abend noch